[Musik]
die konföderierten flagge auf dem
oberarm darüber steht der thriller rise
again also der süden wird wieder
erstarken damals im bürgerkrieg waren es
die südstaaten die sich abspalten und
weiter sklaven halten wollten die flagge
also ein beleidigendes symbol für
schwarze hot legs tattoo ist eine
jugendsünde heute schämt er sich ich war
ein kind aufgewachsen in einer gewissen
südstaaten atmosphäre
mein vater war rassistisch auch wenn er
versucht hat es zu verstecken
und als ich später in eine pflegefamilie
kam war die auch assist in dem tattoo
studio in fredericksburg virginia können
sie sich vor anfragen kaum noch retten
hierüber stechen die tätowierer
kostenlos rassistische und beleidigende
motive für menschen wie project dem als
kind rassistisches gedankengut ein
geimpft wurde
wir binden so leute uns eine e mail zu
schreiben und ein foto von einer
tätowierung zu schicken wir senden ihnen
einen fragenkatalog den sie ausfüllen
müssen um diejenigen herauszufiltern die
sich aus tiefstem herzen veränderungen
wünschen und ihre tattoos die hass
ausdrücken ehrlich betreuung als weißer
aus dem süden müsse man stolz sein auf
die fahne hatte ihn seine familie
beigebracht später freundete sich
potreck mit vielen schwarzen an erlebte
einen sinneswandel die afroamerikaner in
seiner feuerwehreinheit nannte er
irgendwann brüder und sie verziehen ihm
das beleidigende tattoo wir hatten in
diesem job hohe erwartungen aneinander
wenn du ein rassist oder mit
rassistischen unterton redest ich hätte
nicht einmal der hälfte der leute hier
vertrauen können zu dieser zeit mit der
crew hatte ich das tattoo schon auf
meinem arm aber sie haben mir vertraut
weil ich mir den arsch abgearbeitet habe
um ihnen zu zeigen dass es sich lohnt
darüber hin wechselt für eine
überstellung vierte project immer das
geld
dank der aktion des tattoo studios wurde
nun aus der flagge nach mehreren stunden
arbeit eine faust mit regen ab sofort
will er nun nicht mehr nur zuschauen was
gerade in seinem land geschieht sondern
zum echten aktivisten werden
ich denke ich werde mich jetzt mehr in
der blätter bewegung engagieren
ich kann losgehen und meine geschichte
erzählen
das was ich getan habe ich habe viele
erfahrungen gemacht die ich nutzen kann
um wirklich ernstzunehmende
veränderungen in gettysburg pennsylvania
machen sie sich bereit für den
bürgerkrieg spielt heute einen
südstaaten general er und seine jungs
leben amerikanische geschichte wollen
die schlacht von gettysburg
nachempfinden mit originalgetreuen
uniformen und waffen genau an dem ort an
dem ihre helden aus dem süden gegen den
norden gekämpft hatten
das ist ein heiliger ort
hier weht ein echter geist auch der
geist des generals die soldaten aus
louisiana north carolina aus georgia und
virginia
sie sind alle hier der krieg der
rebellischen südstaaten gegen den
überlegenen norden ging verloren
aber bis heute verehren sie hier die
soldaten gettysburg ist kultstätte der
kriegs nachteiliger
den südstaaten ging es in ihrem kampf
auch darum ihre sklaven zu behalten das
blenden viele geschichtsfans hier
konsequent aus die konföderierten flagge
gehört hier selbstverständlich zur
geschichte genauso wie die monumente das
schwarze sich durch solche symbole nun
rassistisch beleidigt fühlen ist für
mike und seine kumpel eine frechheit
seit 100 jahren sind sie daran
vorbeigefahren oder gegangen sie haben
mit der flagge und den statuen gelegt
und sie wissen genau dass sie selbst
doch auch für die unabhängigkeit
gekämpft haben sie waren stolz drauf und
ganz plötzlich waren wir auf und ihnen
wird von jemandem erzählt dass sie das
jetzt heißen sollen warum
und jetzt kommen wir zu der andere frage
dieses ganze dass alle schwarzen ein
schreckliches leben haben sollen und wir
das nicht wahrnehmen realisiert hier mal
jemand wäre der letzte präsident ford
trump war das war ein schwarzer mann
general robert eli ist ehemaliger
sklavenhalter und thront über richmond
virginia zu seinen füßen protestieren
sie gegen das für das er in ihren augen
steht das überlegenheit denken der
weißen den selbstverständlich gewordenen
rassismus also soll die weg karten web
kämpft schon lange gegen soziale
ungleichheit die entfernung von statuen
ist für ihn nur der anfang
rassistische dominanz über eine andere
klasse von menschen solche symbole gibt
es viele
dieses hier ist nur eins das ist hier
ein zentraler punkt an dem der
existierende rassismus zum himmel
schreit wenn sie auch nicht gleich
stürzen können soll die farbe ihn
wenigstens brandmarken und einige
kilometer weiter rücken andere aus um
ihre symbole wieder reinzuwaschen
dort wo in richmond die protestler
abgezogen sind hat bobby eine putztruppe
zusammengetrommelt die waffen haben sie
immer am gürtel
er sei kein rassist betont bobby immer
wieder ganz entschieden aber will dabei
nicht so recht verstehen wo eigentlich
das problem liegt wir müssen
zusammenkommen
das sollte kein weißes oder schwarzes
ding sein es sollte ein amerikanisches
team sein
da gibt es dinge die diese typen gemacht
haben die sozialen nicht mehr akzeptabel
sind da stimme ich zu
das ist ein dunkler teil der geschichte
aber da gibt es bessere wege als kunst
und geschichte zu zerstören lasst uns an
einen tisch setzen und darüber reden
ein zunächst gut klingender vorschlag
der für viele protestler aber nur die
ignoranz das mangelnde
problembewusstsein weißer amerikaner
widerspiegelt sie glauben nicht mehr
daran dass worte die tief verwurzelte
beinahe selbstverständlich gelebte
ungleichheit in den usa beheben könnte
also greifen sie seit dem gewaltsamen
tod von george freut ende mai die
symbolbilder der weißen ein und erfahren
unerwartete unterstützung gouverneure
ordnen an monumente zu entfernen
porträts von südstaatler werden aus dem
kapitol verband aus der staatsflagge von
mississippi soll das symbol der
konföderation verschwinden und auf der
straße ist es plötzlich eine breite
masse vor allem junger weißer die sich
der bewegung anschließt
ich habe schon miterlebt wie schwarze
getötet wurden aber so eine reaktion
habe ich noch nie erlebt dass hier ist
anders wenn ich mir die leute angucke
das hier sieht wirklich nach amerika aus
ich finde es toll dass all diese leute
hier zusammen stehen das kann wirklich
der beginn eines größeren kampfes für
mehr gleichheit seien die vereinigten
staaten stecken in einem kulturkampf und
inmitten dieser stimmung feiern die
amerikaner am vierten juli ihren
unabhängigkeitstag ein datum an dem der
us-präsident zur einheit aufrufen
brücken bauen könnte aber donald trump
tut das gegenteil er macht stimmung
gegen den protestierenden teil seiner
bevölkerung
wir werden nie zulassen dass ein
wütender mob unsere statuen herunter
reist unsere geschichte auslöscht unsere
kinder indoktriniert und auf unseren
freiheiten herumtrampelt donald trump
spricht von wir und uns aber meint damit
nicht alle amerikaner nicht das ganze
volk im rahmen der feiern verkündete er
werde derartige attacken schnell stoppen
wer denkmäler beschädigt soll über jahre
ins gefängnis
heute wird zwingen wir die radikale
linke die marxisten die anarchisten die
unruhestifter die plünderer und leute
die oftmals gar nicht wissen was sie tun
[Musik]
es ist als wolle trump das gegeneinander
einmal mehr provozieren amerika gegen
amerika und einige greifen diese
stimmung auf am vierten juli dem
feiertag versammeln sich rechte in
gettysburg weil sich im internet
gerüchte breit machten die black lifes
matter bewegung wolle hier weiter
attackieren und fahnen verbrennen
sie zeigen die bereitschaft im
kulturkampf auch vor waffengewalt nicht
zurückzuschrecken in stone mountain
georgia tut es ihnen eine schwarze miliz
gleich zum protest gegen südstaaten
statuen haben sie die black power faust
in der luft und das gewehr in der hand
die bilder gehen durch die
amerikanischen medien und das netz aber
zeigen doch nur extreme randgruppen in
einer breiten gesellschaftlichen
auseinandersetzung die für den
aktivisten karten in eine grundsätzlich
richtige richtung geht er merkt dass
sich in den weißen köpfen etwas tut und
setzt auf die junge generation
bei den leuten ist der rassismus tief im
kopf verankert
nicht diejenigen zu sein die die
kontrolle haben ist was völlig neues
verweis dass sie nicht den ton angeben
nicht das letzte wort haben doch die
junge generation ist jetzt mit einer
völlig neuen situation konfrontiert und
sie ist offen dafür
sie sind mit einem so hohen level
politisiert dass sie auch in diesem
prozess ihre stimme erheben
die schwarzen amerikas führen eine
bewegung an und zum ersten mal kommt von
den weißen eine breite unterstützung
hier gibt es hoffnung dass in den usa
eine junge weiße generation heranwächst
die bereit ist das tief verankerte
überlegenheit denken abzulegen
das ist ein bemerkenswerter schritt in
einem langen kultur kampf der mit der
auseinandersetzung um amerikas
historisches erbe beginnt
[Musik]